genau maries jetzt dran machen hey leute
was geht ab heads willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja ich glaube ich schon ganz
lange nicht mehr hier auf diesem kanal
gesehen ich hoffe natürlich wir hoffen
natürlich euch die anzahl deutscher ist
nach sehr langer zeit mal wieder marie
dabei es freut mich super dass du dabei
bist heute hier auf dem westen youtube
kanal auf ganz youtube denn ihr alle
abonnieren sollte und was machen wir
heute
ich habe keine ahnung irgendwas mit
getränken habe ich gehört und zwar geht
es heute um folgendes ich hab's im video
von gestern schon angekündigt ich habe
bei amazon die verrücktesten worum
geht's schon wieder irgendwie immer
hingehen nur rede ist ich habe amazon
die verrücktesten getränke gekauft die
man hier in deutschland bestellen kann
also da gibt es bei amazon getränke eine
sucht sie getränke ich habe getränke
genommen die hat noch niemand von euch
gesehen glaube ich ich kannte die alle
nicht die sind aus japan glaube ich und
südkorea südkoreanische getränk ganz
ganz verrückt und ich würde sagen die
testen wir heute zusammen du darfst das
ganze immer aus konnten hier habe ich
schon so und das ist auch so dass sind
ähnliche glaube ich wir haben mir dazu
zwei verschiedene teesorten also sowas
die ice t ist das wahrscheinlich und
hier steht japans platz eins green tea
und hier steht irgendwas auf japanisch
oder so keine ahnung würde das sogar
fand drauf also wird er in deutschland
auch verkauft und auf diesen flaschen
sind 25 cent pfand irgendwie fühlen sich
volk haltern oder
und hier ist das nächste mal überhaupt
dass gestellt die auch bei amazon gegend
wie stinkt das voll oder ja das ist aber
das papier dann hat das sieht volker
finke na klar ich muss zu trinken also
das sind die getränke die wir hier haben
sie sehen so crazy aber ich habe absolut
nicht sagen was das ist also dass sie so
her kommt das denn manche ist das
chinesische zeichen stehen und rauchen
nettogehälter steht aber sogar was auf
deutsch dass männer interessieren immer
diesem sogar die sind sogar so
angehaucht noch von chris von coolness
selber vor du bist auch angehaucht von
coolness spaß also dann würde ich mal
sagen wir können uns immer abwechselnd
rauswurfs anfang mit welchem song nie
anfangen damit mit dem wir das sieht
lecker aus jasmin dreamteam machen beide
in ein kleines stück rain antreten
das riecht schon sehr sehr künstlich
naja gut
dazu gehört ja dann würde ich sagen
guten durch
das was schmeckt irgendwie nach gar nix
und dann hat das aber schon ganz so
einen kaugummi nach geschmack oder er
ich finde es schmeckt irgendwie klappt
das giftiges getroffen ja das stimmt
schon anschließend ach so ohne zucker
ich trinke einer aus der flasche heraus
das mit möglichst etwas giftiges
getrunken also das schmeckt nicht ganz
ganz ganz komisch dann würde ich sagen
ich möchte hier mit dem pinken
weitermachen
hier haben wir katar
ja mehr kann ich nicht erkennen
erdbeeren ist die geschmacksrichtung ach
so jetzt schreibst du das hier ab hh
hilfe was da was soll das denn jetzt
hier einfach ist das ding jetzt knapp
sondern das nicht sehr sehr süß egal wir
uns eine kugel größter verachtung
tropfen man jetzt kommt ja gar nix mehr
aus hey alter was ist das denn wieso
kommt na ja gut dann lassen wir uns mal
schmecken bei mir ist so brause drin da
unten ist es bei dir auch command da
lässt sich so was auf ich bin gar nicht
so schlecht bitter das schmeckt einfach
nur ultra süß also mir gefällt das sehr
gut
das ist so richtig ist so ein richtiges
freizeitpark getränk ja es so du gehst
im freizeitpark und dann gibt es auch
immer so coole stelle der brust
softdrinks und sogar ist also eine palme
so gefahren und da ist so ein getränk
drin was so schmeckt damit kann man das
glaube ich ganz gut verbinden ist nicht
so schlimm du darfst weitermachen mit
dem nächsten wollen wir dies als
nächstes haben wir dann hier harthausen
mainz das ist nur wasser wir werden es
herausfinden jetzt mache ich jetzt ganz
genau
marie ist jetzt dran nach du das einfach
mal alter wer hat dann so mehr
produziert und so einen scheiß gesteht
mikrofon ich stelle das euch in rechnung
von münster doch dann hätte ich von
einer kurzen und nicht lang schnacken
kopf im nacken
das schon anders breit trifft sonst gut
aber ich muss sagen mir hat das erdbeer
getränk von der vor deutlich besser
gebündelt im nächsten jahr sollte also
ich verlängere ich natürlich die sachen
in der video beschreibung wenn ihr das
auch unbedingt mal testen wollt dann
könnt ihr da vorbeischauen und jetzt bin
ich wer kann und ich möchte jetzt gerne
wir denn japans nummer eins green tea
testen wenn der aus japan kommt und dort
nummer eins ist ganz groß meine hände
gab es kurz die hände waschen
ich schütte schon mal ein ich meine
leute der muss ja was können der ist ja
japans nummer eins greenteam krieg
direkt mal ein bisschen mehr sieht aus
wie pippi wenn man so wenn man halt
lange nicht auf klo war ne oder du
machst mir soviel einig dass so das war
ein versehen das ist wirklich eklig die
armen japaner wenn das platz eins ist
wie kann man das denn mögen also das ist
wirklich das schlimmste bis jetzt ich
möchte jetzt gerne weitermachen mit
harter was ist das hier im moment ich
habe es auch schon gelesen
[Musik]
das hier ist heidelberg ich glaube man
kann sie auch einfach so ließen
doch dann gab es da nämlich dass das für
uns beide
das sieht auf jeden fall jetzt aus wie
powerade das schmeckt echt lecker
ok also hier muss ich sagen von mir
gibt's auch ein daumen nach oben bis
jetzt für mich das beste mit dem er
trinkt dazu und april also den
verschluss verstehe ich nicht der ist
einfach nur kommt wird man unbedacht
vielleicht machen wir es auch falsch wie
gesagt aber eigentlich nicht über eine
anleitung drauf stimmt also einfach mit
druck dann zu halten dann passierte auch
nichts dass ich mal also in den meisten
fällen wahrscheinlich jetzt kommen doch
daraus kann es vielleicht sein dass der
alkohol drin ist und dass das so als
saft getrunken werden soll weil man kann
theoretisch und immer einen shot
eingießen cook war mein okay ich noch
mal den anfang vom herzen getränk auf
dich das ist glaube ich eher waldmeister
als erfüllt das neue lohne melone
wassermelone stimmt ich bin ja so dumm
also ich muss sagen diese greenpeace
sind ekelhaft wie kann man nicht
empfehlen aber das hier ist schon ganz
leis oder
kein vertreter aber die habe ich nun die
durfte ich als kind aber immer wenn wir
kämpfen waren
wenn ihr können war naja leute werfen es
hat euch gefallen das war es halt auch
schon mal unseren getränke test lasse
dann nach oben da moniert den kanal
instagram in der video beschreibung und
wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr wieder biss
dann gibt's neues video
haut rein